[Music]
about choosing this outlet you look
phenomenal
well you know somebody tell you no one
chose you out of a group of pictures
yeah three people normally only wear
white or black and I wanted to try and
mix that up how the whole thing the
Grammys be different for you than
hosting the Tony oh it's very different
completely different show yeah it's
completely different show it's you know
it's a so this is an arena full of huge
music stars and performances this is a
theater where you can necessarily come
out and tell jokes or anything like that
so we're gonna try best to make it fun
what's the moment everybody is gonna be
talking about tomorrow oh man that's too
many I can't quote it right now like all
throughout the last two days of me going
oh that's the moment so you've said
before that Beyonce is your dream guest
for carpool karaoke as she is for all of
us are you gonna picture tonight if you
see or have you already think she's got
some a couple of things she needs to get
out of the way before before you start
thinking about that so nice to see